hello and welcome to this video playing
weak Stefan Stefan Vick from Louise okay
so let's go for the cowl two nights and
2g4 yeah this is um this is the
traditional line Bishop g4 nowadays most
people play Knight f6 but there is
nothing wrong at all about them but the
old main line is just a little bit less
challenging for for white yeah this is a
very standard position that you see all
the time and this variation I'm
preventing Bishop f4 him why does some
try and to make the bishop an account
and you can only do so by being very
patient very slowly trying to to build
up it's um
often check yeah I want to make sure
that he's never going to trade on f4
like 95 and then something to f4
I know it looks extremely slow what I'm
doing I hear Bishop g5 maybe was an idea
basically um forcing the bishop back to
e7 okay I can still play a problem what
you sometimes get here is a completely
symmetrical position on wise if black
plays d5 oftentimes this will be the
best choice and yam he's going he's
going for it it's um
I'm going to take now I guess even
though in this particular situation
Bishop g5 could be an idea
maybe Bishop g5 it's a bit uncommon but
yeah I'm gonna have this pinning
situation the usual reaction is just to
take and then you get this entirely
symmetrical position where White has the
bishop here and can like try forever for
win while black is just sitting there I
was just thinking that this could be an
idea trying to exploit the pinning the
situation um okay so Bishop c4 maybe
quicker route d5 yeah I have to be on
the lookout him I could also play C form
I wonder if the Bishop c4 it's probably
just going 95 not easy they have to see
watch out for my queen and I don't have
many squares got F form but that's it
it basically has to trade Queens now I'm
I'm on f6 yeah but this should be quite
comfortable to play
I've got the four against three that I
can move and I don't think my deep own
is all that weak one problem is that the
e4 pawn his eforp on is kind of
disconnected from the rest of his army
okay is he going for f5 yeah hard to
believe
one night over to e6
hmm I don't know I would also like to
put some pressure on that pawn that's
probably not easy to do okay trying
before be fun
that was the idea okay
I mean it's very early on in the day but
I could have spotted dad that's
extremely stupid to miss him
yeah that's a bleep Adam and a
blind-spot anything ever or something
Bishop I have six is the most obvious
move ever and I didn't I didn't have it
on the radar at all yeah okay if he
takes it now I can get a seven probably
at the end
okay so now Bishop c4 yeah it's got 96
Sun but what can you do have it I went
to c7
uh-huh instead of D I was just thinking
about d6 oh wow this is a really
terrible game on my end
yeah especially considering that this
position type is something where white
can basically never lose unless you play
like a complete [ __ ] which I managed I
mean this is the main objection about
blacks setup I said you can never win a
game with it but yeah you can Lister if
it is played if white is playing as
stupidly as I'm I did
hmm why is he not just taking it it's a
bit surprising
boys down some trick salt
maybe had a connection issue I cannot
quite believe that he would think for
that long in a relatively easy position
I didn't threaten anything here rook is
still quite active
getting bit of counterplay it's not not
really okay I'm not getting the April
maybe mmm
yeah not sure
it's not really doing a good job here
yeah I've got the right it's the right
Bishop even so the ticket is still made
it's funky it's a bit of a joke that I
would endures him because it was
absolutely terribly play game yeah
somehow he had this long thing when I
feel there was some distraction that was
probably lucky break for me yeah yeah
the bad thing is that what makes this a
bit annoying is that this is really the
kind of position that white is playing
for two results owned him maybe my idea
to allow me for was just wrong the
normal solution is what the engine is is
giving here is simply taking and then
something I'm not sure about this now
what what the best move are is and maybe
take him and put this on to see form
this is what you normally get and this
is the position where you can play on
for white forever and ever and ever and
ever because of your bishops and you can
long-term you can try to give trade
Queens this is one thing that is an
important thing if you trade Queens you
can advance all those pawns here basis
based on the bishop pair like f/4g for
g5 something that black can also easily
do with the bishops with their
long-range capabilities they prevent
those advances for black but I can play
a for g4 and so on a gain the space in
case of a Korean trade
first of all I have to catch up here in
development because what setup is quite
slow of course this is not the end of
the world for Blackie absolutely not but
what the engine is giving is 0.5 0.4
whatever this this kind of evaluation is
probably exactly justified white is just
very slightly better for forever and
maybe this was not as good as I thought
yeah
and see for that 98% of 6 was strong him
probably that wasn't right then Queen b6
already okay didn't really think about
it but it is extremely logical that's
better than g6 yeah yeah I felt I should
define G form is very normal
maybe it's too slow it's not a priority
it's a move you want to play here but
it's not a highly important move at the
very moment problem
yeah Bishop b3 rook c1 is stronger and I
want to hear there should be three then
D sorry
25 okay d form this and now this is the
next move is kind of a kind of a joke it
simply did not see Bishop f6 it simply
did not F three years probably right
hoping from something like that to
happen where again I'm going to be
slightly better forever dad simply
didn't see the move okay g5 that's nice
nice idiom
now at the engine correctly points out
that this is going to be compensation
him
what a piece yeah before b6 black black
gets very nicely coordinated and I have
a bad bone structure
okay okay
I tried d5 d6 and Bishop b5 you having
Bishop c4 I didn't see that this was
what was happening and he I'm just a
pawn down for solution but here it took
a long time a really long time yeah
he I'm starting to get some play the F
pawn currently is not doing that much
and Queen side but it's just happening
I'm no loop C 7 X is 7 now okay that's a
lot stronger before taking I don't have
this obviously okay it's supposed to be
okay according to the comp
hard to believe actually sorry for the
noises I haven't had breakfast yet
King be three and just equal it says
yeah maybe if the King cannot invade the
bishop has some problems moving and you
can never really move into this
direction because of this idea yeah okay
we fit 0 0 0 according to the comp this
is just a draw yeah yeah I don't know
this is starting to get annoying for him
ma'am yeah remind ok guys thanks for
watching